fora tv' idea immersion
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation Brian Eno has been
with long now from the start he named it
the long now foundation he gave the
first talk in this series of seminars
about long-term thinking and he's a
member of the board and is known as as
well as being one of the great
contemporary musicians and composers and
artists a very very comfortable and
creative collaborator with other people
and so on sort of a trial basis tonight
we'll see what it's like to put a
creator of music with a creator of games
games with four computers are really
news that stays news first serious
computer game was space war forty-four
years ago in 1962 written by a group of
hackers at MIT who was at Steve Russell
mainly along with Alan Koh Tech Peter
Sampson and Dan Edwards ten years later
1972 this was written in rolling stone
space war was the illegitimate child of
the mating of computers and graphic
displays remember back in 62 computation
was something you sent off to the
manufacturer you sent the data away like
color film and then it came back days or
weeks later hopefully usable but not
always space war was real time there was
the illegitimate child of mating of
computers and graphic displays it was
part of no one's grand scheme it served
no grand theory it was the enthusiasm of
irresponsible youngsters it was dis
reputably competitive it was an
administrative headache it was merely
delightful yet space war if anyone cared
to notice was a flawless crystal ball of
things to come in computer science and
computer use it was intensely
interactive in real-time with the
computer in encouraged new programming
by the user
it bonded human and machine through a
responsive broadband interface of live
graphics display it served primarily as
a communication device between humans it
was a game the function best on
standalone equipment which is a big deal
in those days that served human interest
not machine a lot of the work being done
then was trying to keep the machines
interested and games didn't care if the
machines were interested or not and
mainly it was delightful I wrote that
1972 44 years later computer games still
lead the way and we'll right leads
computer games
please welcome Will Wright and Brian Eno
[Applause]
thank everybody can you hear me test
yours can you hear me thank you thank
you all very much for coming and the
format tonight is slightly undecided but
essentially we're going to talk about
games generative music and what those
things do for us and what's different
about them from things we've known in
the past and I'm actually the assistant
here this is this is really wills talk
no not really
I've been encouraging him to basically
interrupt me at every stage overcome his
English reserve show up that's the
spirit we're going to talk and interrupt
each other for about an hour and then
there will be questions which I think
you know to write down on pieces of
paper which will be thrown away at the
back of the room and then Stewart will
ask the questions he want to ask us
anyway now you know okay I'd have to say
what an honor it is actually to share
the stage with Brian whose work has been
just very inspirational to me for as
long as I can remember so thank you
can i reciprocate that I think so I'm
gonna do some boring PowerPoint at the
beginning of the talk and I think
Brian's gonna score my boring PowerPoint
with very interesting experimental music
so you know I actually just got back in
town recently a few days ago and I was
trying to remember what time the talk
was and so I went to the website the
long now foundation and saw the talk was
Friday June 26 which consulting my
calendar I found that those two things
were incompatible an ironic for an
organization whose sole Charter is to
chart this passage of time but when when
you're dealing with 10,000 years a few
days doesn't really make that much good
yeah so I think we're missing half the
audience that probably came here Friday
but so I wanted to start just a little
bit just by delving into compression a
bit because I think a lot of what we're
gonna talk about this is underlying it
and I know that all of you find the idea
of compression just fascinating but
really it's the basis of a lot of really
interesting systems in fact you know
what we know is science is really
observing the natural world around us
you know all the data that we can see
and collect and observe and trying to
compress it into the simplest most
elegant rule sets possible you know in
some sense we even use that as a
guidepost you know when Watson and Crick
discovered the structure of DNA they did
it by building these models in them but
they tripped across the idea of the
double helix and it was so aesthetically
pleasing to them they just kind of knew
it was right and games really are just
kind of the opposite process we're
trying to come up with very very simple
rules that we can decompress into these
elaborate worlds and I think the kind of
work that Brian's doing as well kind of
speaks to that looking for very simple
systems that can generate really
interesting complexity it's it's called
laziness really yeah but yes I I suppose
the thing that most impressed me one of
the musical things that most impressed
me in my life was a piece by a composer
called Steve Reich which is an extremely
simple piece in terms of the inputs and
the system it's it's two two loops of
tape that run out of phase with each
other
get progressively more out of phase and
thus generator a very complex piece of
music and I was so impressed that
something so simple could create
something so powerful when did you do
that
that was 1964 I think that piece it was
called it's gonna rain and it's the
amount of actual sonic material in the
piece is 1.8 seconds long but the piece
is 30 minutes long or something like
that oh really so we're the duration of
the two pieces well it's the same loop
on two machines 1.8 seconds long and one
machine runs slightly slower than the
other so gradually they the relationship
between the two loops
shifts and in fact that's been the basis
of a lot of the music I've done since
then music for airports for example was
based on that idea and a lot of the
ambient music is based on this notion of
instead of trying to design a piece from
the top down which is what you normally
think of as composition you know you
have the whole piece in your mind and
then you sort of build it all like an
architect makes a building this is this
is more like a gardener you you have a
seed and you plant it and you see what
happens you know so so when that seed
comes out and it's not what you like or
you explain you I mean yeah so it's much
more of the process of discovery rather
than composition or engineering yes and
you're sort of in the same position as
an audience actually because you're
you're listening to the music for the
first time as well so so the music is
generating itself anew for you the
listener as well as for the audience so
it's it puts the composer in an
interesting new relationship to the
music I think yeah I mean I think as a
creator it also puts a big challenge on
you because now you're in the process of
exploring rather than engineering or
sculpting yeah so you have to care about
your inputs and your systems a lot more
since since you aren't designing the
whole thing you are not specifying in
detail the whole thing you're making
something that by definition is going to
generate itself in a different way at
different times so yeah we see that a
lot with simulations because we're
always looking for a very simple rule
structure
we build into prototypes and we just try
to long and see what happens and then
from there we will start modifying them
and it's very much the process of
surprising discovery mm-hmm and it's so
not longer it's so counterintuitive that
it's very difficult to kind of have an
end result mind as a target and then
shoot for that it's actually far more
productive to just kind of experiment
and let the results of those experiments
kind of present opportunities to you
yeah you know that oh that's really cool
you know I never would in a million
years have thought to go there but these
simple rules brought me there mm-hmm
yeah well this this is sort of a new way
of being an artist really I mean it's
not so new now people have been doing it
for 30 or 40 years but to to make it
explicit and say this is what I do and
to own up to the fact that what you're
doing is making seeds rather than
forests you know yeah letting the forest
grow themselves so I thought we would
delve into this generative systems
across a broad range of topics here you
know kind of one of the preeminent ones
is biology and this is one that we're
very familiar with a Richard Dawkins a
biologist estimated that typical willow
seed actually only contains contains
about 800 km data which is enough to fit
on like one of the old floppy disks
which is really amazing when you imagine
all the trillions of atoms and all the
complexity in a willow tree that the
genome of it compresses down to that
small it's very powerful ratio there it
also we see examples of this in things
like behavioral sciences you know ants
have very simple rules but when you
combine those simple rules they display
amazingly elaborate intelligent behavior
spirograph is a great example one of the
most understandable examples you know
using simple geometry but another
another example of a very simple
generator system like that is wind
chimes of course that's a that's a
generative system that oh yeah I think
we don't take very seriously but in fact
in fact that's like the first generative
music do you think I think it probably
is yeah okay only an Aeolian half is
probably the first one actually it's an
interesting question I mean do draw a
distinction between let's say randomly
generated music like wind chimes and
algorithmically generated where there
are some deterministic rule underneath
the system well it's one part of course
of the wind chime thing the most
important part isn't
random which is the pitch of the notes
the notes oh so the only random part is
when they when they occur and how they
cluster together and that sounds
generative to me have you done systems
that involve more randomness yes what in
the sand itself or in the selection of
the nodes yes yes so I've experimented
with all sorts of forms of randomness
and I found that I nearly always end up
constraining it quite a lot it seems
like it's some level complexity you
wouldn't even be able to determine
whether it was random or there was a
very complex algorithm underneath and
that's that's true yes they become
functionally identical because it seems
like a lot of the aesthetic for music
involves patterns repeating patterns
that listener can kind of start to
identify and anticipate as they're
coming up well that's what I call
narrative music that's true but in in
the 70s I came up with this word for a
kind of music that more and more people
were starting to do which I called
ambient music and that was quite a
different idea that was the idea of
music as a sort of steady state
condition that you entered stayed in for
a while and then left okay so as music
as painting more than as narrative so it
doesn't have beginning it doesn't have
development it doesn't have climaxes
particularly it's it's closer to sitting
by a river than watching an orchestra
for example yeah I actually spend a lot
of time listening to your albums during
ambient albums and I found them
interesting because it was a whirl of
them in a very subconscious level
it wasn't like most music where you're
hearing it you're thinking about it and
kind of starting to kind of get into the
rhythm and stuff but it would just
totally change the perception the world
around you without you even realizing
that it was your audio system doing that
it seemed almost subconscious and you
stayed awake yeah actually do a lot of
work to it you know the other music was
just like where on me after a while but
the ambient stuff is giving to this
trance-like state in fact it was
interesting because it brought me into
this relaxed trance-like state but kept
me
somehow kept my brain active in a area
that I wasn't even aware of yeah well
I think some of that music came out of
trying to find something I could listen
to while I was trying to work alright
yeah okay so you did like your other
music notes too while you were working
to attention-grabbing
mmm you know it's designed to grab your
attention exactly in that part of the
brain is what you want to apply to your
creative work yeah you know and somehow
it keeps that part of the brain fed you
better go in with that okay loads of
slides right yeah we do we're never
gonna get to spool or otherwise yeah
fractals rattles
you've seen these L systems yeah yeah
this is the boring PowerPoint part of
the lecture
all systems are actually an interesting
form like fractals that allow us to
generate very organic looking shapes and
they come in a variety of kind of styles
but it's actually quite amazing that
there are patterns embedded in this that
you can clearly see but the same time
there's a very organic nature to them
these are more l-system things a lot of
art I tend to think of as generative you
know where artists will use very
primitive elements but in combination
they evoke totally different feelings
much more complex forms you know my
favorite painting Kandinsky yeah even in
design we're starting to see more people
will use generative system cristal
examiner's work is very much about this
how he looks for patterns rules grammars
to apply to design there are other
things known as shape grammars which are
being used in things like architecture
and industrial design these are ways of
applying transformations to certain
design rules to generate new designs
that you can then go through and prune
and kind of score for efficiency when
you do music and you're coming up with
these rules there must be some process
of you playing with the rule set
listening to it saying I don't like that
playing with rule set again so basically
pruning out the rules you don't like to
zero in on the rules you do like yes
exactly and and finding out that one
always in client is inclined as a
composer to put more in than you need as
a listener so so one of the very good
things about working on this is that
there's a speed control
oh so you listen to these things in
first board I work on them much faster
than I end up releasing them Jeff oh
really yeah and in the days of analog
tape that a lot of the
music I released was released at half
the speed I recorded it there's like
people doing the film editing we're
always living through the thing on this
is the opposite of what people do on
television where they always accelerate
you know hmm I find with music if you're
making it you always tend to fill the
gaps you want to paint the whole picture
but if you're listening you you actually
want a lot less than that so I do that
the simplest way it's just by slowing it
all down you should release an album
with all the speeded up versions this is
as Brian heard it while composing it the
amphetamine version right yeah really
I'm Fetterman ambient jazz we see
generative systems in psychology you
know it's amazing how humans can see
patterns and almost anything and we're
always searching for these patterns even
if they don't actually exist
and we've even engineered things you
know that kind of bring us more into
meditative spiritual realms that in some
sense regenerative systems for the mind
and games of course are a great example
this is my favorite game of all time go
which has two simple rules but yet the
strategy is just amazing the way it
unfolds in kind of very unpredictable
ways and you know this is one of the
clearest examples of generative systems
and emergence that I've ever seen this
this game by the way there's a book by
Frances Fitzgerald called fire over the
lake about the war in Vietnam and she
once interviewed of Vietcong general
after the war and she said why do you
think you were so successful he said
well the Americans are playing chess but
we were playing go and that really
captures the difference between the two
games goes about a hundred times more
complex than chess really in terms of
the range of strategy yeah and in fact
the compression ratio between the
simplicity of the ruleset
and the depth of the strategy for here
it's just an amazing ratio I think that
ratio is interesting in the entire world
around us looking at like the DNA versus
you know the willow seed and the willow
tree you know that compression ratio
indicates a certain level of generative
system you know and emergence a lot of
that is based upon symmetry that you see
in a lot of different ways
and symmetrical operators rules when
we're building models on the computer
you know a lot of these become games and
in some sense you know models are
abstractions of reality and what they
kind of remove is interesting they're
only presenting you with relevant
information when I do a game I actually
build physical models of the stuff when
I did a game called The Sims involved
this screen of the neighborhood and one
of the first things I did was actually
go build a physical model of it out of
like model train materials and that
abstraction is kind of interesting to me
we abstract things not just spatially in
games but also in time you know time is
something that you can play with on
computers and interactive systems in a
totally different way than you ever get
the opportunity in reality one of the
most important things about games is the
fact that they have you know restart you
can replay the same situation over and
over from the exact same starting
position which you never get the
opportunity to do that in reality then
some sense I guess regenerative music is
the same way well this this is one of
the very interesting things about
generative music that you can start it
again and it unfolds differently and
this is this is very fascinating because
it it implies a sort of space of
possibilities that you gradually become
familiar with so instead of becoming
familiar as you normally do with a piece
of recorded music with this particular
story you become familiar with a sort of
envelope of possible stories that the
music might unfold along yeah in fact
that's exactly the same thing happens in
games you know the players are kind of
exploring raesha snakes exactly
illustrates what I just said yeah
you must be on the same wavelength in
games you know the computer actually
when it's playing chess is actually
analyzing every possible move that you
might make and it might make and it's in
fact building a map of all the possible
moves up to some level of depth that
might happen in the game and that's how
computer a eyes work and even board
games in some sense become a map of the
possibility space you know all the
different spaces on that board indicate
states that you can be in in this game
most people just don't think of it as a
map really in that sense we can think of
our games as these in fact very
elaborate landscapes where there's
terrain and the Train might represent
challenge difficulty some areas are very
you know smooth slopes that you can
climb up very gradually other ones are
steep cliffs that are incredibly
challenging the hip so there's in some
sense of friction to the possibility
space in an interactive experience and I
guess when you're working on music
there's a certain amount of probability
that you might enter certain regions of
that possibility space certain regions
may be more probable than others yes I I
remember one very funny thing that
happened once I to use a particular
generative piece for all of my sound and
light installations for many many years
and I must have listened to that piece
for thousands of hours unfolding in its
various different ways and I was setting
up a show in Venice once with my
assistant and it was late at night and
we were setting out it was that the show
was due to open the next day and
suddenly the beginning of Tammy Wynette
divorce so a pure chance
pure trance yes the thing had suddenly
clustered together to produce the first
couple of bars of divorce and we're both
very tired and we looked up and just
fell on the floor laughing it was so it
never happened again
we just didn't listen long enough dr.
nerse because that kind of implies the
vast space that music you know occupies
the fact that it took that long just to
hear one tune out of the thousand one
tune that I recognize that several
thousand dollars yeah so they're kind of
implies that composers are finding this
very small amount of listenable space
yeah within this vast you know
astronomically large sea of potential
sounds yeah and it's as you know
whenever you think of a space like that
and you think of the possibilities that
have been explored so far you
immediately start to think of all the
ones that haven't been explored like if
you think of the space of all possible
seashells and then you think of the
number that have actually been explored
it's a very small part of that right and
you want either that to I mean there's a
quality rating so most of the random
compositions you can make probably sound
awful
correct and so you're looking for this
region of yes quality since yes you want
to be on the cusp where it's where it
doesn't sound random but it doesn't
sound too obviously too predictable
it doesn't unfold like you expect it to
but it doesn't unfold in an entirely
unexpected and disconnected way either
so you explained this huge space it
makes me wonder if there's any no
algorithmic solution to at least find
some rough measure of quality so you're
not having to sit there and listen for a
thousand hours to get a sense of you
know the quality of the entire range on
that system well that's a moving target
you see because whenever you listen to a
piece of music you
you really are listening to the latest
word in a conversation that you've been
having ever since you started listening
to music you know you hear every other
piece in the piece you are listening to
at that moment so as your taste changes
and your experience changes that target
will change all the time I think
can you imagine as any sort of even this
first past computational filter that
would pre listen to the music you know
analyze the structure look for patterns
whatever that would at least prune out
the 90% that you obviously don't want to
listen to and let you focus you know
your efforts on the 10% that has some
promise would you like to work on that
you just have to give me the algorithm
I'll get it coated right up for you know
it's it's funnily enough there's been a
lot of research into that because um you
know there are always people trying to
figure out how you write a hit oh I see
yeah formalizing something I wouldn't
mind knowing the hit generator yes sir
so there's been there's been all sorts
of attempts to do that but they've
they've been astoundingly unsuccessful
so far yeah I can imagine
difficulty unsuccessful in fact they're
almost there almost formulas for doing
the opposite oh really yes also they
were interesting in that respect thing
that they they're they're
counterproductive it sounds colleague
stock trading programs yes yes you know
you're hitting this you know moving
target that you know in so many
dimensions at once yeah very good sorry
oh yeah I know we've got you all right
there's gonna wrap us over the knuckles
if we have these possibility spaces the
players are navigating and in some sense
as designers we even think about we're
engineering these possibility spaces in
a very kind of abstract sense in the
sims we actually had two main dimensions
that the player would kind of pursue as
a goal state well he's a material
success getting larger house better
career etc and one is social getting a
larger family more friends really one of
the players to kind of balance the two
factors and that would lead to the
highest level of success in the game
they could go for one of the other and
they would end up on a local maximum
some since the game was very much like
bowling if you kind of went off to the
side you'd end up in a gutter and you
had to get it right down the middle to
get the highest level of success in the
game this is actually a map that we made
of several thousand players playing the
game across those dimensions and so
we're actually able to formally capture
you know players movement through these
possibility spaces and start to analyze
kind of where players you know
coordinating you know coming together
where are they fanning out in diverging
and learning a lot of interesting things
about that I think a lot of times with
linear storytelling that's what's
happening as well this is one of my
favorite scenes from Indiana Jones where
the beginning of the movie where he's
running out of the temple with his
treasure and all these traps are going
off you know he almost falls into this
pit this giant bowl mister all rolls
over him
and as a viewer I'm imagining every one
of these things as a possible failure
state what would happen if the ball
rolled over and what if you fell in that
pit what if this trap got him and so
even though I'm seeing one path through
that possibility space my imagination is
filling out all the possibilities that
could have happened and that is a lot of
the drama is me understanding the
possibility space that surrounded him
and the one particular path he took
through it and I think that's the
element of a lot of drama oh now we go
to stuff stuff yeah stuff at this point
I think Brian's gonna start playing up
some music there you go all right we
thought we'd give a few examples of some
different systems
and once you describe what you're
playing and I will if I can get the
volume right
I have to get this balance between the
way you can hear it yet still here up
so actually all the pieces I I should be
playing today I made today because
that's the power of generative systems
like that is the Clary it because
because I have a new computer which was
supposed to have all the contents of my
old computer it was only when I arrived
here that I discovered it had none of
the contents of my its Willow had
viewers it just had the names of all the
contents of my own that's a very
powerful feature so rather than just
recite the names to you I made several
new pieces of music and programming
terms that's called dangling pointers
who don't know this this piece was meant
to go with oh yeah yeah we're now we're
getting on to the exciting so these are
a cellular automata which probably a lot
of you are familiar with and the idea
behind these is that there are very
simple rule systems and we run the rule
and it actually analyzes every cell in
here each one of these cells looks at
its neighbors analyzes what's around it
to determine its new state and so it's
the same rule apply to every cell but
because the number of neighbors is
different you get different patterns
emerging so I'm stepping through this
very slowly okay we just we should
perhaps give the audience some idea of
what these rules are like they say
things like if three if three of your
neighbors are alive you're going to die
or you're going to survive in the next
generation if you've got only one
neighbor alive you'll die if you have
two neighbors alive you yeah persist
whatever and that's the exact rule said
those kinds of things is probably the
most well-known example of a sailor
automatons and this is Conway's life and
that's his rule set basically you've got
three or four neighbors you survive you
have exactly four neighbors and this is
going into every little cell and
Counting how many neighbors you have to
determining whether a new cell is
created or destroyed and
[Music]
please one more I shouldn't have but now
as we've run these I'm gonna run it fast
now you start seeing these amazing
patterns develop and this is entirely
deterministic so from this versa there's
only those three rules and what's very
very interesting is if you make a tiny
difference at the beginning it can
translate into a huge difference in the
lifecycle of the thing so you know if
you start with a grid of nine nine
squares with one added to it it'll last
for 53 generations if you add one more
Square to last for 15,800 generations
and this pattern I'm showing here every
time I run and load it it will generate
the exact same result and so all of the
complexity you're seeing as it runs here
is embedded in a couple of simple rules
and these are very interesting systems
because there are so many different
things that you can kind of generate
with them different patterns symmetry
some of them are very beautiful and this
is actually we're playing with this a
little bit earlier today and we were
noticing that certain pieces that Brian
was composing went very well with
certain rule sets this was somewhat
unpredictable as to which ones went well
together but it's actually too
generative systems basically kind of
playing off each other having never even
that I'm reluctant to play this tool and
though because I think it's a bit
disturbing to have that's that's lovely
now I'm actually pulling back on this
pattern this is way zoomed out and as we
zoom in closer and closer you've seen
different patterns of different scales
here so what you have to think about is
suppose you had to make this as a film
what we're seeing here it would be very
complicated that's a lot of information
if you had to specify it as as a visual
phenomenon like that but what actually
has happened is that there's this tiny
little set of rules and this landscape
for them to work in and the set of rules
is well it's typically like a 2k
document or something like that and you
get all that richness so so this is the
really the power of generative systems
that
you make seeds rather than forests and
these are very much the type of thing
where you have no idea what its gonna
look like we need to build the rules you
turn it on and it's always just a total
surprise these were actually developed
when I couldn't take the four news by
one moment before you really even had
fast digital computers to run them on
and another interesting thing about
these is how fragile they are so because
this one for instance if we go back to
the starting position you can see it's
just two simple cells as we start
running the pattern it starts expanding
but it's totally symmetrical bilaterally
symmetrical girl and as we run it it
maintains that symmetry to its entire
life but if I pause it just for an
instant and add one cell somewhere where
shouldn't be and then run it it will end
up breaking the symmetry so now we've
broken the symmetry just by putting one
cell in the wrong spots so these things
are very complex but also very fragile
in some sense they're very dependent on
their initial conditions as well so so
what they start out with totally
determines their life it's actually a
very very sort of sad view of human
possibilities really sure how fragile it
all is and how nothing can change much
well you see that biology a lot actually
the genetic structure is such that you
know only the viable organisms will
survive and so every one of your
ancestors had to you know survive to
reproduce and a lot of times they're all
regions of evolution that are cut off to
us because we have to jump across this
chasm yeah one fitness yes I sometimes
wonder about my ancestors on that score
this
this is another example of things that
we can do with these systems we can I
just put a little see this is a this is
a little machine you see yeah very
little machine and I can like put one
little cell in the wrong spot here and
very quickly the whole thing just kind
of goes to crap that was you know one
cell and and now the full cycle is
broken these guys are going off forever
or that direction we can actually use
these things for doing simulation in
fact a lot of our games are built upon
cellular automata at a very simple level
to simulate you know what seem to be
very complex things SimCity which is one
of the games worked on many years ago in
fact is under laid by just I said a very
simple cellular automata like this you
know they have very simple rules for
things like crime and traffic and
pollution and on top of that we lay all
these nice graphics of cars and
factories and all that but really
underneath it's a very simple grid based
system like this it allows us to
simulate things and it took a while to
discover the rules but once we actually
put together a few simple rules we got
two systems where we were seeing
emergent phenomena we were seeing things
like urban gentrification you know just
do the simple interactions of the crime
land value rules and stuff like that it
seemed like it was a much more complex
simulation than in fact it really was
let's go to another little example here
this one is a little more visual in some
sense this is a simple program that
actually has some very simple rules for
figure drawing and poseability the
figures and what it does it generates
paintings basically on the fly it kind
of knows how to draw a few things like
plants and I know what this this is by M
was it bernhard cohen who wrote this
what's the name of Harold a Willie let's
find out and I will register this I
promise
oh let's find out
that was Chris wall yeah it's from Chris
wall but every time you run this
basically it generates a new painting
and it's interesting just because the
computer is obviously doing you know
fairly random redistribution of the
poses and the figures and the colors and
whatever but they're still evocative
it's interesting I can look at each one
of these things and there's a certain
mood it's kind of you vote for me and
looking at them that I'm sure the
computer wasn't thinking about that at
all but this this is one of the other
interesting things about generative
systems they depend a lot on the
observer as well so one of the things a
lot of my work counts on is the idea
that if you put something onto a CD
people will tend to think it's probably
music the cost of the CDR but it's funny
it's like if you if you put something in
a frame and hang it in an in an art
gallery people will think it's a
painting and and they'll reserve the
special kind of attention for that which
they don't give to computer screens or
to their shoes or whatever so so I think
something I'm very aware of is that
people tend to connect things together
in their brains I mean I a lot of my
work involves using light and sound
together and I never synchronize them
but people always think that they're
synchronized in ways do you use light
like light shows or that's a big long
story I don't think we should go there
actually oh no I have to well if we get
time later but that that takes a long
time ok I I don't want to I want to get
to spore basic ok well we can do that
right now on and then we can eat your
long story that looks like Julie
Christie maybe this okay let's switch
screens over to this computer in audio
if we can so
I'm gonna show you a game that I'm
working on right now that relies very
heavily on generative systems and it's
called Spore
the rough idea was inspired by the
powers of 10 which is a book and movie
done by Charles Mary Ames actually done
earlier by a Dutch school teacher named
case Boca
called cosmic view but I'm sure you've
seen this either the film of the movie
where you have a guy laying in a park
and it zooms down to the Sailor level
atomic level all the way down to the
quarks and then it pulls all the way
back up to you know the planet the Sun
the galaxy and I always thought it was a
very unique perspective and it was kind
of missing the dynamics I always wanted
to see the dynamics when different
scales so that was part of this brush
behind Spore another part of it was
allowing the players to be able to
create most of the game so almost every
piece of content in the game is created
by the players I'm just gonna show you a
few bits and pieces of it here the game
actually occurs across multiple scales
from cellular to kind of evolution
creature up to tribe city civilization
and in space in fact you're actually
kind of developing evolving civilization
from a single microbe every level the
game also has an Associated editor where
the players in fact actively creating
the content I want to show you kind of
an example of what that looks like
because a lot of the underlying elements
of the game involve the players having
very powerful editors so this is our
creature editor in the game and so it's
a very simple kind of skeletal system
here where I can drag out things I can
inflate them with the mouse we want to
be extremely open-ended to the player we
have a palette of parts over here that
we can kind of grab and use and stick
onto the thing
very play like you know everything I can
basically kind of sculpt like clay
different types of parts use your feet
as I start putting parts on the future
starts coming to life I could kind of
morph and scale these things you know
let's give them out here
[Music]
all these parts have handles let me
scale this up
maybe give it some more
[Music]
a set of arms
that's gross now the interesting thing
about this is that no matter what the
player designs the computer has to
figure out how this thing would behave
so here in a few clicks in about two
minutes I've created you know a fully 3d
character next up is actually coloring
the thing now this is all generative as
well so basically we have simple rules
for how the computer should paint this
thing so we basically select a color and
then each one of these spoons here
represents a different algorithm that
puts a different pattern on the creature
so you can go for stripes spots scales
we can overlay and mix different
patterns so I can pick another color
here and then put different stripes the
computers actually analyzing things like
where the torso is where the legs are
very much the way a texture artist would
and in fact you know typically a
computer texture artist would spend a
couple days texture and creature like
this so here in about three minutes you
know in about maybe 30 miles clicks I've
created a creature that's roughly
equivalent to what a Pixar artist might
create over several weeks
and now the computer actually analyzes
what we've made and brings it to life so
in fact this is the way this thing would
move and so no two preachers will
actually kind of move or behave the same
way in this game so can I just interrupt
them in its only you see the ways you
see there were hits heaving up and down
there yeah that's is breathing right so
so is the computer told in every case
just to say what would this thing do
when it breathes I always do that sort
of thing it always makes a decision
about yeah everything it does the
computers making some decision and
sometimes it's abstract out elements of
the creature you know maybe it's mass
and weight and size the way it moves is
very based upon how long the legs are
how many feet yeah you know you can move
in radically different ways if I put
like seven legs or tentacles or whatever
so there's a range of possibilities that
the computer has to kind of understand
based upon the structure for the future
39 so everything that creature is doing
in the game all the behaviors have to be
animatable by the computer algorithm as
well as emotions so we have to be able
to show you know the features happy or
sad I wouldn't depending we designed
that could be you know quite tricky so
we take this creature and we actually
bring it into the world and you're
actually playing in a full world of
other creatures that were designed by
other players so as you design a future
in this game
you're actually interacting with other
creatures that other players have
designed automatically and how is the
how is the sentient on the creatures
that you interact with chosen it's
chosen by the computer based upon what
you've done in the game so it's based
upon how well you are as a player your
skill levels based upon a number of
other things so do you as a player can
you reject a sense so if the computer
puts you in a landscape which you don't
like very much can you say I'd rather
have another set of creatures please
well in some sense later stages of the
game you can do that you can give the
computer kind of directives on the type
of content you want so it's trying to
select content it's not only appropriate
before your kind of skill level but also
your aesthetic style so you make some
purchasing decisions in the game make
the selection decisions yeah the
computer tries to abstract it very much
the way Amazon recommendations does and
so in the game I basically need to find
food to eat
we're gonna go over here I hear some
cutie picking exhibit here now again my
creature is doing everything out
rigorously based upon how I've designed
it now these guys aren't very strong but
they're very social so that's sticking
up with each other so even though
they're weak I'm not gonna get very far
with them so I'm gonna go or something a
little bit easier here we go some people
herbivores over here
if I'm quick I could go get a bite of
their egg here happy about that their
ever worse but they hold up in their
mouths but I did get some DNA points now
not only am I just trying to survive in
this but there's a whole social game if
I can find members of my own species
like this I can basically socialize with
them and it's my brain level advances I
get the higher Nova speeds and higher
levels of communication
now this one's ready to mate so I can
actually mate at this point of the game
and this is out rhythmic mating
that we banned in several states yeah
so I actually play every generation on
my creature through evolution and that
gives me access to the editor again and
can I ask you something sure if your
creature doesn't survive the illusionary
struggle yes what happened basically you
like the restart thing that I showed you
earlier oh I have to defend my eggs here
basically if you died in this stage of
the game you would fall back one
generation to your last egg and get an
opportunity to redesign your future Isis
the next generation so this is the
creature I had now I might decide I want
to make this picture faster so what I'm
actually doing is playing every version
of my creature every generation of its
revolution so I'm gonna take off these
feet put on something a little bit
faster and this is how I actually
increase the performance of my creature
over time and do you do you pay extra as
it were for these yeah you know for
high-performance features yes in fact um
there's a currency the yearning kind of
DNA currency that you're earning in the
game that you didn't spin in the editor
so at every level the game so if you
design something like a sloth that would
actually be very cheap with it yes in
fact you could actually start as a slug
we have this little slug thing we called
Oggy okay you know I had basically a
mouth you know and that was about yeah I
knew someone like that yeah
it was a very tricky you know Larry the
guy survived with now I'm gonna make my
guy a little bit scarier you can also
make changes to your guy that are more
aesthetic now so my happy-go-lucky guy
is gonna be a little more serious here
and then let's go back in a p.m. can you
can you also modify the behavioral
characteristics or does the computer
give use those from from what you've
done physically in the editor you're
designing the physical characteristics
of your creature once you get into the
game you're actually designing its
behavioral characteristics by the way
you play it so if I play my creature is
very social then it will start to
reflect that in the game by how often I
socialize with my other creatures they
might become more of a herd mentality
and work together like the small
creatures we were at before so here i've
read these on my creature but as i come
back into the game we actually don't
start with the full size we start with a
baby so this is the baby fide version of
the adult that i've just designed we run
actually a little simple neonatal
algorithm and so you see the head is
exaggerated and a few other things and
so the social game i can actually click
on these guys and have them socialize
play together and as i do that i kind of
earned this is like playing the
friendship game in the sims and these
guys will then start to follow me and
mimic what i do so here we're playing
together
now at this point the guy will become my
friend I get the little friend thing and
now I have roughly follow me around and
I can get a little pack of my little
baby friends here and we can go over
here and we can kind of like annoy our
neighbors the herbivores again
[Laughter]
[Music]
those guys are a lot bigger than we are
but we're pretty fast yeah they're
getting annoyed now they'll definitely
get us but I'm gonna skip ahead here a
little bit now we actually made a
skipper long low intermediate levels of
the game eventually you develop
intelligence and you start controlling
an entire tribe of these guys and
control their technical advancements you
can get them things like fire Spears etc
you can design things like their Hut I
can every level the game you're doing
things the player is creating and using
generative techniques underlying that
that's what makes it possible for in 20
clicks the player to create something is
that we've made so much of it all over
Hollywood to make the computer side so
that gives the player a huge amount of
creative leverage the computer becomes a
creative an amplifier to the player
eventually you start building the entire
cities and you can design the buildings
in the cities eventually vehicles as the
civilization start interacting with each
other and I'm gonna skip way ahead here
this is gonna be the same planet that
we're on the same creatures but this is
basically at the end of the civilization
phase and so at the end what the end of
the civilization phase so these
creatures have you know advanced all the
way through you know tribal city and Civ
and now there's a high level of
technological advancement you can get a
sense of some of their cities all these
buildings were designed by the player in
the editor the cities that you're
competing with we're designed by other
players in the editor and downloaded
your computer automatically to basically
fill out your world as well as the
vehicles etc here so here's our home
city now at this point in the game we
can click on it and we can go to the
next stage of the game where we're
actually entering this space for inside
of the game now the UFOs that we have
here are like anything else is ahead
Claire can create them and this is our
civilization that you were playing as
evolution earlier now basically entering
the space age and so there having been
launched
so we have a little celebration now if
you play the game I'm actually kind of
controlling this UFO and flying around
the planet this is the planet that we
evolved on we've been playing the entire
game on this plane up to this point you
can get a sense of some of the other
styles of buildings this is some of the
other cities that I basically built the
game now at this point of the game one
things I might want to start doing is
going out and terraforming and
colonizing other worlds one things I
might want to do is collect biological
samples on my world I can do this with a
subduction beam that allows me to kind
of go in using real scientific
principles here so as we suck these
things up into our UFO they go into the
cargo hold and we can use them we
actually one thing we found that was
kind of interesting is that we could use
the abduction beam to throw things
really far we may have to get some of
these guys into orbit
but now also for the first time we can
like pull all the way out and see the
entire planet that we've been playing on
so and these planets are generated as
well so using very simple rules we were
able to generate you know entire
planetary systems so as we pull back
here we can see that even if had got
kind of a very slight and ling around
our planet as we keep pulling back we go
out to the interstellar view I mean the
a planetary view so here's our home
solar system that we evolved in these
are other planets this one I can tell
has some type of life on it so we're
gonna fly over this planet
and pull down the surface again these
planets are all generated auguries mcli
and we're
that's right in these plans
this one's a bit more kind of
fantastical imagining
so we're going to take our future of our
own planet and start introducing them to
this now this planet already has a whole
atmosphere and in fact somewhat of us
simply
some of the other planets are more
barren in fact you have to kind of
bootstrap from the very early stages
onto this level so let's find a spot
over here
we get a little stunned when they get
dropped
[Applause]
okay they didn't get along with the
neighbors too well
one things we can do is we can scan
these guys with our scanning tool and so
any other creatures that we see on this
planet we can scan they're entered into
a database that we call spore PDF and
now that database we can access and
spore pedia basically is a record of all
the content that we've come across in
the game so in some sense this is kind
of a collection game there's a card
that's built for every piece of content
so this is our home star the planets
around it I click on that and I get a
plants this is our home planet this is
the place that we're currently visiting
right here if I click on that these are
the species that I've scanned on this
planet each one has ratings etc and so
we can use that to kind of keep track of
the stuff that we've come across in the
game is is it um is progress in the game
always hierarchical in the sense that
you you start at one level and you
proceed up the echelon well could
somebody for instance come up with a
virus that actually had a planetary
impact
so somebody specializes on at the lowest
level and doesn't decide to evolve into
a larger creature oh you can stay at
different levels but the idea that we
would be simulating viruses at the same
time that we're simulating the entire
planet is basically kind of unmanageable
you know from the computational point of
view so in every level of the game we're
abstracting out the levels below and
above and we're actually running very
low res simulations when you're not
there at different scales but when you
go back there we have to regenerate the
content and so a lot of this is us kind
of propping up the illusion of thousands
and millions of things all running at
the same time but we're really doing
with abstraction and regeneration so to
give you a little bit better example of
that is we pull back from this now at
some point I can upgrade my UFO and
eventually I earn the ability to pull
all the way out from our home solar
system to the interstellar view so this
is a region of interstellar space around
our home system with other stars we have
a lot of other things that you might see
in the Hubble telescope things like
black holes nebula etc we can fly to
each one of these
and these are in many cases worlds
created by the computer in other cases
the worlds created by other players so
if we zoom into one of these worlds here
one of these new solar systems we now
see different set of planets here and so
this one close to the Sun is very hot
rocky planet this one it would be a big
terraforming challenge we can pull down
like the last planet was a very
imaginative kind of almost Disney like
planet this is in fact a much more
realistic planet this is very much like
the early Earth was about 4 billion
years ago kind of a hot volcanic world
here pull down to the surface we could
bring up the sound a little bit some of
these worlds as you're exploring them
you'll come across things
there might be hailing artifacts or
things you can kind of scan into your
UFO so there's a whole kind of astok
exploring this vast world and the fact
that we can generate an infinity these
worlds kind of means that never you
never run out of things to explore a lot
of these planets are going to be in
higher civilizations that other players
have created that are brought down to
your computers copies and so as you play
the game it's keeping track of not just
the creatures that you've designed but
in the entire planets because you can
sculpt entire planets once you get to
this level with the UFO so here's
another world let's go over this is
actually got civilization on it and this
world is orbiting this gas giant it's
actually kind of a moon around this gas
giant here and this was created by
another player but it's asynchronous in
other words the other player is not
online right now what happened is the
computers observe the way the other
player played this they might have
played this is a very peaceful race or
trading people or explorers and the
computer tries to stay fairly consistent
with the way that player has basically
programmed their behavior so we're gonna
go up and read them do your impacts on
that planet register on it permanently I
mean that will they be there for the
player when that player returns - well
see one of the points of this is that we
want every player to be able to be a
hero in their own universe and so I want
to be able to do whatever I want to do
on this planet without ruining that
players experience so this is where it's
asynchronous and this is why I'm playing
with a copy but at the same time the
other player is gonna get a report of
how many people came in and trashed his
world or made alliances with it or
whatever so you get reports back from
what we call the meta verse which is all
the parallel universes that people are
prizes again so these guys are kind of
wondering why we here you know at this
point I might try maybe firing some
fireworks
okay they like that
you better
now the relationships I can develop with
these other races go number of different
ways we could end up being trading
partners we can end up you know forming
an alliance or Federation well in this
case they decided to worship us so as
gods had tiring yeah so we might pick
one of them up and bring them with us
okay so they didn't like that's how we
treat each other that was bad okay that
we treat us but I have weapons somewhere
here oh here we go yes shoot back at
least I have to take off this planet
Earth sorry basically inadvertently
smart though interplanetary war here
kind of a major Americans are doing that
yeah that's about right keep your hands
to yourself no comment there okay
obviously taking out their defenses and
so now I can do whatever I want with
them but uh at this point I should
probably run you know them out it was an
accident you know actually the thing
that we found is that the terrifying to
intelligence was wrong yeah I can erase
the evidence just by bringing a few
comments down this is actually
terraforming tools that we use for
bringing oceans to a planet and so if I
drop enough comets on here the ocean
levels will start rising here and I
could eventually erase what I've done
hopefully this is the global warming
fast-forward version you can pretty much
we create here we should do it
alright now as we point now we don't
know if this is you know the home rolled
of this species or just a colony okay so
they're upset sorry as we pull away from
this we're getting another message on
our comm screen okay so we just started
a war and in fact that was just one of
their colonies so now we have to head
home to defend our umbrella but so this
region of space we're looking at here
represents several thousand stars you
know the player can explore you know
many of which are player generated
meaning of widget computer generated but
even this represents just a very small
fraction of the entire world the player
can actually plan we're actually dealing
with several million worlds that are all
unique and the only way that can
actually happen is the fact that the
world is continually this galaxy is
communally being created by the
collective efforts of a million players
as they play and underneath all of that
is the power of these generative systems
and you know giving the players that
kind of amplification you know through
these editors you know that those
generative systems provide but so that's
the Spore demo fantastic Thanks
[Applause]
so I think we're right on time for the
Q&A stuff right so stuarti you're gonna
read the questions or should we just
okay well I've had a question if
requests if you can put your screen down
a bit the people who have been wondering
always looks like for a while here's a
question from looks like Bert Balki
where are you there okay do either of
you have any comments on how you we
should think about intellectual property
and authorship in a world of generative
design that's a very interesting
question which as you can imagine I've
thought about a fair amount I've just I
just released a new thing which is
called 77 million paintings by Brian Eno
it's a it's a generative work 77 million
77 million yeah and it's a piece of
software and there was a lot of
discussion about how he would protect
the results of this so I decided to
finally put a sign on it which says any
of these pictures of available for you
sexually well 77 million any or 77
million and then it says and but would
you please give me a credit because
there's no there's absolutely no way of
protecting them and and anyway I don't
particularly I would never know if
anybody used them because I'm never
gonna see more than 200,000 of them in
my life so that's a lot 200,000 and well
it's probably the exaggeration I mean
with us we have the issue that we're
building these systems that players then
use to build content themselves and
infrequently other players will take
that content make something else you
know we had like in the last version of
the Sims a machinima tool to where
players can make movies frequently they
were downloading other players creations
their characters or houses to make the
movies and so we have so many different
layers of authorship yes at some point
it gets just horrendously complex you
know well it's been like that in music
mouth
fifteen or twenty years you know I mean
of course the record that I made in this
city actually my life in the bush of
ghosts is a very good example of a
complex authorship problem because I'm
on that record I used other recordings
it was unusual learned to do that but I
used other recordings as my lead
vocalists preachers or people and get
permission and well I at that time of
course we didn't do that kind of thing
because nobody knew there was gonna be
any money in it it sounded so weird at
the time yeah so so I did apply for
permission and in fact when the record
was mastered and ready to go one of
those permissions was refused and we had
to junk all the records we've made and
all the covers and put another track on
in its place we actually do that three
times actually what one interesting side
effect of this whole thing that I found
is that it puts us in terms of
commercial companies producing stuff in
a position to where there are certain
things we cannot do but our fans can do
because they're not doing it for
commercial gain and they're basically
under the radar doing grassroots stuff
so they can build content and grab stuff
and collect it and make these kind of
remix things and then put them on their
website so we could never put on our
website so in some sense it gives the
fan communities a whole reason to exist
because they're come under the radar of
this legal issue actually we we just
have another interesting example of this
going at the moment them so my life in
the bush of ghosts has just been
re-released and the record company with
that usual flash of brilliance that
record companies show when you re
release a record since let's put some
remixes on it as though nobody had ever
thought of that ever before and of
course it always happens and they want
you to put sort of six horrible dodgy
remixes on your wonderful record David
Byrne had a much better idea David Burns
my collaborator on that record which was
to make a website where we would put the
individual tracks of some of the records
you know the guitar part the bass part
this and that and so on onto a website
so that anybody could make their own
remixes and then post them back on the
site yeah actually I've got some if you
want to hear them later they they're
really very good that the remixes that
people have done they're amazing so much
what's the URL on that brand where do
people find that online it's called
bush of ghosts calm bush - of - ghost
calm and it's it's fascinating what
people have done and what's very
interesting because they all have weird
names like blast XP and write lobotomy
and have no idea who anybody is
there's just this stuff flowing into the
site and and visitors to the site rate
it so there's a chart in there you know
which the things people like best and so
when people started using the sims to
tell stories and movies and stuff was
the first time that is a creator
I thought the fans were entertaining me
just as much as I was entertaining them
yes yes I I wondered seriously about the
idea of making a whole record like that
not actually making the record but just
putting the parts up saying to the rest
of the world here's some interesting
bits try sticking them together for me
okay here's a related question pure
question it's actually the same question
from two different people
dan ancona and a mark live okay the
first version is there are a lot of
really interesting political assumptions
embedded in the simple rules that drive
Sim City would you ever consider open
sourcing a version of it so we could
play with those assumptions and then the
second question is spore makes a lot of
political assumptions about the basic
evolution of civilization it seems what
do you think about a game where you can
model various generative politics maybe
play with fascism
kisum were you naming okay that's a
brilliant idea by the way I have to say
that's like yeah that's uh that would
certainly be let me go to the first
question about Sim City is that we have
looked at giving the players more access
to the rule structures underneath in
fact we did a simulation called Sim
health but I know it sounds terribly
exciting but it was a model of the
national health care system where the
players could actually get under the
hood and adjust the rules and
assumptions in fact I think you know
when people play some city and they get
to the point of starting to argue with
the assumptions of the simulation that
means that the game has been successful
because they have coalesced in their
mind the model of the game and how it
differs from their own viewpoint in some
sense it helps coalesce their own
internal assumptions and when they could
start arguing with it that feels to me
like a really good result of the game
now giving people access to the
underlying algorithms again it's not as
simple as you might think in that we're
dealing with these generative systems
and that we spend a lot of time
discovering these rules they gave us
reasonable looking traffic or crime or
whatever so it would more be the process
of giving them access to the very
underlying generative structures and
letting them discover other rules so
that's something that would be a very
different thing than a game in terms of
open sourcing it we have done that with
some of our really old stuff and we've
seen their interesting results
especially like in college programs when
people are reprogramming like Sims
objects and things like that so yes I
think I'm very open to the idea it's
probably harder than it sounds for most
people in terms of Spore and the
political stuff that would be kind of a
different direction I think
civilizations sid meier's civilization
goes into that area much more thoroughly
that we can afford to in Spore because
we're trying to cover so much ground
spores more about breadth and about
player creativity than it is about you
know delving deep into any one
particular aspect of it later said a
related question bad Bateman allowing
that all creativity may be in some form
derivative Brian this you've said and
art is about art is the creativity
inspired by games more akin to fan
fiction believe - what - fan fiction
fans of Star Trek making their own
Star Trek right things like this or
people writing you know their own
versions of stories Harry Potter has a
whole world of other people's versions
of Harry Potter hmm well I think game
certain games are allowing more and more
access to the underlying content where
players can modify the actual objects
and in some sense in fact it's kind of
interesting because we're starting to
see games not just using his
entertainment or education but his tools
of self-expression as I said before
players are making stories and even
movies with the Sims you know originally
these were very simple little stories
about superheroes but later they got
very deep very elaborate stories you
know about their you know
autobiographical experience is very
heartfelt things and it was interesting
to me that something that starts out as
a piece of entertainment eventually
becomes a tool for people you know and I
think kind of what you come out in your
website you know people are probably
drawn to that because it feels like you
know music I'm gonna listen to these
pieces and some way they start playing
with them sticking them together like
Legos and then they start realizing
creative aspirations well there's a
couple of questions your will and are
you aware of sort of SimCity being used
by real urban planners are you things
that behaviors that people have
developed in the Sims that they then go
out and try and real live you know one
of the things that we've discovered it
and you know this very well is the fact
that we thought back in the sixties when
computers came out that we could
simulate the world if we just had enough
data and we had no elaborate enough
algorithms but later we discovered this
thing called chaos theory which says
that you know basically interesting
systems are inherently unpredictable and
we have very severe limits on the
predictability of things like weather
and social systems and economies and for
that reason a model like SimCity no
matter how elaborate you make it no
matter what type of supercomputer you
run it on has fairly limited
productivity value and they're making
much better as descriptive models and
we're educational models so I know a lot
of planners have used SimCity to
introduce other planners to GIS systems
geographic information systems just the
idea of you know basically digital
access to the content that they were
normally dealing with on paper
and it also allows people to kind of get
its some sense of the underlying
dynamics of a city in a very simplistic
caricature fashion but we've seen people
go the other way where they take aspects
in the real life their real city and
then model them and things like the
sounds or in some city one of the things
that we have a lot of girl players for
the sims in fact over half the players
are female and one things I hear so
often is like fifteen-year-old girls
they put their themselves in the game
and their boyfriends and simulate their
interactions and they go tell their
boyfriend what happened their symboi
friend did to them and I think it's more
to hear his reaction to the fact that he
was floating with this person over here
or whatever but in some sense they
treated kind of almost is a voodoo doll
or a spreadsheet you know for why but I
tend to think of it more is it's a
scaffolding for their imagination these
are things they might imagine anyway but
the game just becomes a scaffolding for
it here's a question from Ken pon Tech
where are you how come I never have it
enough time what I thought that was you
talking what me to probably everybody
here and one of the issues is is playing
with time you're doing it with music in
some ways taking people into a timeless
place with the least the ambient music a
non narrative non beginning middle end
non time event but these games will that
you're designing and others are
designing seem to compress time and a
whole lot happens you're not necessarily
in a narrative sense but a whole lot
happens in a relatively short time
you're taking these creatures from
spores to space in a matter of I don't
know days that doesn't usually happen in
the real world as far as we know well I
think the experience of time is very
very elastic indeed if any of you have
ever been involved in a serious accident
and had that experience of your life
rushing before you and you know a one
second or a half second actually
occupies an enormous amount of time you
can see every detail unfolding in that
house
and when I got this cut on my head that
that was getting hit by a London taxi
there very heavy I can tell you I cut
knocked over by one but I was so
fascinated by the fact that so much had
happened in my mind that in the hospital
bed I managed to write a 10-page piece
about everything that had happened in
that half second right yes it was a bit
like those physicists who deal with the
first three nanoseconds all right do you
think when you do your music do you
imagine the perception that you're gonna
give the listener of time what does the
ambient stuff stretch time for people I
think so yes
yes I well that's that's what it does
for me and I hope it does it for other
people it it kind of smoothes time
actually it stops it being jerky and
urgent and discontinuous it it's like a
regular whale it it smoothes it and
makes it into a continuous thing just
for a bit I tend to think of you know
games and even storytelling as almost
technologies for us dealing with time
because we're basically our perceptions
are embedded in the time stream we never
have the opportunity to go back in the
past but things things like storytelling
you know if I come out of the cave and a
tiger almost eats me I can go back and
tell you and you never experience that
but the next time you leave the cave
you're gonna look out for that tiger you
know basically I have taken this
experience out of time displaced it into
you and you had that experience yes and
in games you know players can restart a
level try new options explore that
possibility space and so these are you
know tools that we also use our
imagination for all the time as we're
building models and you know kind of
running scenarios in our head all of us
dealing with the fact the simple fact
that we are embedded in the timestream
and we do not have mobility through it
mm-hmm
but you know in the type of stuff you do
I think you do have almost a throttle in
some sense you know I think you're kind
of throttling the flow of time for the
listener mm-hmm yes and of course if you
you do that with rhythm no end you know
you you do it by subdividing rhythm and
by missing out beeps where they ought to
be that that really increases the
experience
I think it's like your punctuating time
yes you create a grid and then you you
don't observe it you miss certain parts
out of the grid and that gives a very
funny feeling of a huge hole it feels
it's like that feeling when one of your
teeth breaks you feel its enormous hole
in your mouth just because you're so
familiar with what should be there you
can do that with rhythm I think as well
it does the blank space that really
defines yeah that's what reggae is all
about actually reggae is about creating
great big holes where you expect there
to be beats really Brian watch it q up
one of those pieces that have come on on
your website well I asked another
question
I know even though they do these things
at once from Kevin Kelly how these
generative systems changed your sense of
long-term thinking that's a question for
both of you
sorry what's that question how these
generative systems changed your sense of
long-term thinking males aren't very
good at multitasking you know putting a
CD on completely occupies all of my
brain well of course a lot of the pieces
I've done have been effectively infinite
which which is very interesting to make
pieces of music that know what nobody
will ever hear the whole of so I sort of
liked that idea I used to when I used to
do one period doing installations I
would you know the way in art galleries
they always say dimensions of everything
they say so this piece nineteen feet six
inches by eleven foot nine and then I
would say music estimated length six
thousand four hundred and ten years
so does that give you a better
perspective on the basically the ratio
we talked earlier about the compression
ratio between the simplest you know set
of rules generating these huge amounts
and some since it seems like that's kind
of what you're alluding to there is the
back to these simple little loops you
know out-of-phase in fact will not
repeat for 67,000 years or whatever it
is yeah it's so it's so elegant I think
it's so it's so economical I mean
especially with the shows I do in
galleries I nearly always show people
exactly how the trick is done there's
normally six or ten CD players each one
playing its own CD and the CDs aren't
synchronized so this is one of the bush
of ghosts remixes by the way so one of
the fans made this yeah I think for me
the as I played with these generative
systems and try to simulate more and
more aspects of the world I've see the
kind of world around me now as both
simpler and more complex than I which
they thought you know I do bridge
initely thought of it as being under
light but these fairly complex rules you
know that had some kind of finite space
to them now I actually see the world as
being built out of these incredibly
simple little things interacting that
are actually driving a much higher level
of complexity than I really thought yes
exactly so that so the rules are simpler
but the outcomes are much much more
lurid than one had ever imagined right
and it's not a straightforward
transposition of some of these simple
rules to that outcome yeah it's a very
magical very counterintuitive thing
that's that was the thing that most
attracted me about life that one of
those cellular automata I remember when
I lived in San Francisco in 1980 they
had a very primitive version of life on
a computer at the Exploratorium I
remember that yeah
I used to go there every day I used to
fight people off it well he's annoying
annoying children would come and what if
they had it ringing hardware they'd
actually built a hardware machine so it
wasn't even being run software seems
like extremely fast for a wife at the
time it was fantastic and I I got to
know this thing so well then I
eventually was appointed as an explainer
a kind of honorary most ways just sorry
because I didn't want to get get off it
but what fascinated me was the
counterintuitive nature of it because I
you know if you're an artist you sort of
flatter yourself with this idea that you
know your intuition you work with your
intuition and here was a situation where
your intuition was absolutely useless
and making predictions yeah and it was
that disconnect between these simple
things door was a very suitable
situation you would think with something
as simple as that surely predictions
would be very easy yeah did that
actually spark your interest in
generative music yeah that was part of
it yes so that that tied in with the
Steve Reich experience and some of the
things Terry Riley had done there there
was there were various things going on
in music but they hadn't really
consolidated into an idea but I think
life was what really sort of clicked it
for me and do you feel like the the
visual example of life is having these
simple rules and leading to these
elaborate things do you think that's the
same rough kind of thing that you see
when you're doing with children of music
I mean they're kind of unpredictability
you see yeah
yes I mean the the great thrill is to to
put together something that is much more
beautiful than you could have imagined
you know you start out another working
base if they have a cup of tea things
together try some rules and suddenly
something beautiful comes in just like a
discovery yeah that's how it feels my
discovery that it feels like creation
yes exactly yeah destruction I got a
question here for you silly order of
Tommy tongs it's interesting that both
of you have locked so totally into that
because it is such the sort of founding
the generative thinking for a lot of
people this question is from Bob
co-packer do you think Katrina or the
tsunami and Sumatra were caused by one
pixel mistakes by which mistake well in
the cellular automata where this this
was the sort of butterfly effect theory
wasn't it you know this this was the
idea of chaos theory that you know a
tiny tiny piece of behavior in some part
of the universe would eventually
compound into something huge in another
part but that's what restart is for us
when that happen
that actually brings up an interesting
point because there is a big difference
between weather and climate mm-hmm you
know so chaos theory does operate at the
level of weather where small
perturbations the atmosphere could
possibly create a storm system but in
terms of climatic changes which you know
as the oceans get warmer or sea levels
rise those over statistical periods of
time are probably much more stable and
much less random than we might think so
the you know probability of bad
hurricanes occurring is most certainly
going to go up over time if the oceans
warm that's a certainty really but the
fundamentalist chaos theoreticians would
say yeah but climate only got that way
because some butterfly many many many
millions of years ago flapped its wings
yeah I don't personally believe this so
I think thing
and it's unrelated by very elaborate but
yet almost glacial processes you know
very with a lot of inertia to them that
I think that a hurricane could possibly
be created by some small local
perturbation but in terms of climate in
terms of the frequency of really bad
hurricanes occurring over the next 10
years that is most certainly a probably
a long term trend you know based upon
very deep cycles of the carbon cycle and
things of that nature I did a game while
back simearth which is actually
simulating a lot of these cycles and it
was actually interesting how many of
them were related across disciplines so
you had certain people up here studying
the weather other people studying
geology other people studying the ocean
but all these things are tightly
interconnected and we're just now
starting to realize how interconnected
they they are yeah a couple of specific
questions for each of you one from Brian
good for Brian you know did you utilize
generative systems when producing you
two albums in in some ways I do use
generative systems in that I sometimes
come up with sets of rules for people so
if there's a sort of creative impassive
cause if things are going fine you don't
need rules good things are going and
fine but very often you know things hit
a wall and nobody quite knows what to do
and when you don't quite know what to do
what you normally do is fall back on
your habits so I often think of ways of
breaking habits like getting people to
switch instruments for instance or
getting people only to use a small part
of the range of their instrument you
know play the guitar only on those top
frets or getting into role playing for
example them when I was working with
Bowie on one record we did I wrote some
sort of scenarios but clubs of the
future for the year 2015 so I I invented
this club on the outskirts of Tripoli
and invented a kind of music that they
played I described the kind of music
that was played there sort of as sort of
post techno African rye or something
like
and then invented the kinds of
instruments that they would have and
what sort of personalities the players
have and so it's like a role-playing
game actually but the result of it was
music so so we tried to occupy those
roles and you imagine that there are
instruments were those instruments and
try to get them to make the kind of
sounds those instruments would make so
those kinds of things that I think very
very useful even if they don't
specifically produce pieces of music
that you use though they sometimes do
what they really do is break habits and
sort of open you up to new ways of
listening and doing things I work more
and more that way with musicians these
days try to just think of new ways of
starting to think about making music so
it's kind of like you're stuck in a
creative local Maxima and you want to
knock yourself off that Maxima through
some strange process to try to find
another one exactly yes it's it works
especially well with people who've who
have worked together for a very long
time and if people have worked together
for a very long time they have one great
strengths which is that they're quite
telepathic but they have one great
weakness too which is that they're very
often over diplomatic in that you know
because in order to keep the group's
solid and happy nobody really wants to
say to the guitar player who's just
spent four days on one part it's not
very good but in a role-playing
situation you can actually because
you're not you're not that person any
longer you're you'll know no you're now
this new character who always says
things like that yeah do you see what I
mean well a couple of questions for you
before have parasites every complex
ecology is mostly parasites about Spore
I'm sorry
it's a Spore have parasites not overtly
you know again that's an avenue we could
have gone down that would have involved
a great deal of confusion on the players
part we want to keep things you know
very high correspondence between what
they create in the editors and the
results they get into the game
if you get into things like parasites if
I design this great creature and I
painted it all up and also need eyes
have a cold you know it it works for war
the world's is the punch line but there
are a lot of things that when we do game
design we either break reality or
conveniently ignore aspects of it
because we're trying to engineer a
certain experience on the part of the
player right so games are not about you
know put everything into them that you
possibly can in fact really the hard
part is a designer of games is deciding
how much stuff can we possibly remove
and still maintain their core experience
one of my favorite quotes
there's about Japanese gardening and
it's that your garden is not complete
until there's nothing else which you can
remove and I think you know for me
that's very much design you know what is
the simplest smallest thing that you can
put together that achieves the design
goal yeah I think about music that very
often the same way and I start off
painting so putting everything on and
then I end up sculpting cutting cutting
stuff out it's Laurie Anderson's album
in a big way took all the music off it
oh that's right yes so yes when I was
working on that album when we came to
mixing yeah I got I worked out a
procedure for mixing and I cuz I loved
her voice so much I thought I'm going to
start every mix just with her voice and
I'm gonna see how long I can listen just
to her voice before I want anything else
to happen now I have a very high
tolerance for her voice so I probably
would have never put another instrument
on if only been down to me that with
advice I would gradually bring other
instruments in hmm okay another question
here we come back to reality from Jessie
Cohen sharp do you this is for will do
you see physical reality virtual reality
and gaming merging in the future if so
how while you're pondering your answer
to that
Vernor bingo has this answer out a brand
new science fiction book set in 2025
called rainbows end which plays out this
very question in exquisite detail but
will you probably have another sense of
how the interaction might work
well I think they are merge right now
because I think you see things happening
you know in when I call cyberspace or
you know over the net that very
definitely impact you know the real
world in fact you know our perceptions
have changed as resulting these
technologies the computers turned out to
be more of a communication tool than a
computational tool so I think in a very
real sense they are merged I think even
in things like online games you have
real communities of people forming real
relationships
you know and a lot of them you actually
ending up meeting getting married or
whatever so these are definitely areas
where socialization is occurring where
communities real communities are forming
even though they happen to be online so
I would say this is one of the kind of
most rapid transformative experiences
that our culture has gone through in
history you know in fact the internet
you know it's Kevin Kelley pointed out
is 10 years old is astounding you know
when you think about how its impacted
our world you know in 10 years that
we've come to rely and so much of what
we do is moved into this medium that yes
I think they are very much connected
already you'll be in the thick of it is
good or heading toward a big finisher so
9 o'clock
Roger Lynn asked some both of you what
did you really want to talk about but
nobody asked or another version of that
is what did you really want to ask the
other person on the stage but we did
have we did have an idea actually that
well that we might talk about what
happens to people when they play games
he was going to talk about that and I
was going to talk about what happened to
people when they engage in culture
generally but that's a long story I mean
that's too long stories you guys to see
long stories yes so I think the culture
and work back to the game I'll bet you
can do a short version yeah start with
culture ok ok
my definition of culture which I've used
for quite a few years now is culture is
everything you don't have to do so you
have to wear clothes at least in this
climate you do but you don't have to
wear these particular clothes we could
all just wear sacks actually couldn't we
you have to eat that you don't have to
develop complex and beautiful cuisines
so so there's a layer of things we have
to do otherwise we wouldn't survive and
then there's a huge layer on top of that
which is stylistic essentially and we
spend a lot of our time thinking about
that stylistic layer so I started asking
myself since that's the layer that I
make my living in a long time ago why
are we so interested in that what are we
doing when we engage in stylistic play
like that and I think it's a to cut very
quickly to the end of this one our
explanation I think what's really going
on is that we are engaging in some kind
of simulation activity so when we look
at stylistic things we're very sensitive
to what's different in one hairstyle for
example than another and we're very
sensitive to what those differences
implied to us you know he's got a rather
feminine hairstyle he looks really gay
he looks very masculine
he looks this she looks that and we we
read these cues from hairstyles quite
without thinking about it and we make
choices about our own well
and so what we're doing always I think
is when we see any stylistic object
where we're seeing in that a little tiny
microcosm of some kind a little set of
implications about a world picture and
that you know you can see how that's
clearly the case in a novel but I think
it's also the case in an earring or in a
cupcake a decorated cake you know
so I think what we're doing then is
we're constantly looking at these things
to imagine what would that kind of world
be like what would it be like to be that
kind of person who wears that kind of
hair what would it be like to like that
kind of picture and I think we we do
this at sort of some levels of remove we
watch ourselves doing it we watch
ourselves surrendering to objects of
culture because we can surrender to them
because they don't hurt us essentially
that's the the best thing about art is
that it isn't life you can switch it off
or walk out walk away from it so
therefore you can surrender to it as
well and the the act of surrendering to
something is really the act of for a
little while agreeing to live in that
particular world with its particular
values and seeing what it's like and I
think this is because the strongest
difference between humans and other
creatures is that we're capable of
imagining and that's exactly what
imagining is imagining is the process of
imaginative thinking what else it could
be like how else things could be and we
practice that all the time I think with
with objects of culture that's a very
poor explanation really but I can make
it much better if I had longer
[Applause]
that was excellent what was the other
question
this is this is dueling intellectual
where does that connect with games both
of you well actually I think I think of
games and play and actually a quite a
bit of overlap with your answer in that
I see these as tools that we use for
first of all perceiving the world in
building models in our head you know in
fact when we do these computer models
those aren't the real models we're
building the real models were building
are in the players head the computer
game is just a compiler for that mental
model in the player and you know we have
this ability as humans to build these
fairly elaborate models in our
imagination and you know the process of
play is the process of pushing against
reality constructing a model refining
the model by looking at the results of
us pushing and interacting with things
you know one of the probably chief
aspects of our survival as we became a
social species it was not just modeling
the world around us nature but modeling
other humans you know which in fact were
probably the most complex things we were
interacting with you know we probably
learned things about the seasons and
about the Predators in a much simpler
level than the complexity of other
humans and so that's what we started I
think developing this deep ability of
empathy to look at another person to get
a sense of their motivations their
feelings what they're likely to do next
and I think that became the basis of
what we call storytelling so as I'm
watching a movie or reading a book I can
imagine myself as that actor on screen
in fact that actor is really just an
elaborate simulation of a real person
experiencing those emotions having those
motivations that we can displace
ourselves into temporarily and
understand what it would feel like you
know just like you were saying we're
looking other people what would it be
like to be that person yeah that's an
amazing human ability almost like a
psychic in its level of you know detail
you know I could look at another person
just with a glance and get a sense of
kind of what they're thinking what
they're about to do so I think
storytelling basically was built upon
that empathic circuit and I think play
which is probably the other major
educational technology
that evolution developed was based upon
the idea of agency but in fact I can
touch the world interact and observe the
results and start building models of
that world so I think a lot of our
understanding the world and the way we
perceive it is through those two avenues
you know and one is pretty much the
domain of playing interaction and the
other one is more the domain of linear
storytelling and transferring experience
across time
why does play the common verb here
playing music playing games that's a
good question why is play the common
verb you play music you play games yes
yes and it is in most languages as well
really it's not just in English yeah yes
I don't know it's makes perfect sense in
a way that it should be no that one is
what is exploring
exploring a territory called music just
as one explores a a game it's almost
like play is a word that was designed
not to be precise mm-hmm you know
because we fight there's so many
different things yeah it's almost the
whole purpose of that word is to cast an
umbrella over activities that we do not
want to be overly specific about yeah
and leave a certain amount of creative
latitude to its interpretation yeah you
guys know the book Homo Lord ins homo
Luden's by yeah yeah
you've live it keep living it you guys
are phenomenally generative this has
been a I suspect generative evening or
there are any final admonishments or
statements you'd like to send us out
with well I must say I thoroughly
enjoyed it and thank you for very
interesting questions from the audience
really all good questions weren't they
yeah they were hard yes sir thank you
very much and thank you as well I yeah I
think Brian to give us some music and
we'll process out of here thank you okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you